und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend das saas kopf 2 virus ist kein
lebewesen bloß eine infektiöse
organische struktur
es kann deshalb keine eitelkeit
empfinden über den sozusagen
ritterschlag von queen elizabeth the
second in ihrer ganzen eine ewigkeit
währenden regentschaft ge route sie erst
drei mal ein vorkommnis im königreich
mit einer persönlichen ansprache zu
würdigen
die bedrohung ihrer untertanen durch das
virus war ihr nun noch einen vierten
solchen auftritt wert die queen hatte
sich dabei den grenzen der britischen
monarchie geschuldet jeder politischen
bemerkung zur lage des landes und zu
versäumnissen ihrer regierung zu
enthalten
solche einschränkungen gelten natürlich
nicht für den bericht unserer
korrespondentin diana zimmermann corona
hat das königreich fest im griff der
premierminister selbst ist am virus
erkrankt die regierung steht für ihr
krisenmanagement massiv unter kritik da
hilft nur eins die queen muss ran den
briten zuversicht geben und an die
eigenschaften erinnern mit denen das
land nicht zuletzt zwei weltkriege
gewonnen hat wenn sie einig und
entschieden bleiben werden wir diese
krankheit überwinden
ich hoffe dass in den kommenden jahren
jeder stolz darauf sein kann wir auf
diese herausforderung reagiert hat
unsere nachfahren sollen sagen können
dass die briten unserer generation so
stark waren wie jeher und das
selbstdisziplin ruhige gelassene
entschiedenheit und mitgefühl dieses
land noch immer charakterisieren wäre
die 93-jährige eine normalsterbliche so
stünde ihr momentan nicht mal ein platz
auf der intensivstation zur verfügung
leiter von alters- und pflegeheimen wird
empfohlen bewohner über 75 nicht ins
krankenhaus zu schicken
sie würden dort ohnehin nicht mehr
behandelt angst geht auch um unter
menschen mit behinderungen
200 von ihnen darunter john hayes die
haben an die regierung geschrieben
der promovierte politikwissenschaftler
leidet an
muskelkrankheit und befürchtet nicht die
gleichen chancen wie andere zu bekommen
ich habe alles getan was ich konnte der
gesellschaft so viel zurück zu geben wie
ich kann wir sind keine statistik wir
sind lebende menschen
bitte schreibt uns nicht ab ihr
gesundheitsdienst ist den briten zwar
heilig aber nicht viel geld wert er wird
aus dem staatshaushalt finanziert und
gerade in den letzten zehn jahren der
sparpolitik wurde überall gekürzt
jetzt mangelt es an personal ausrüstung
und zunehmend an sauerstoff
medizinisches personal flieht die
bevölkerung um unterstützung an
es ist wirklich hart wir müssen sie
kämpfen ich werde euch alle nur sagen
bitte bleibt zuhause
wenn ihr zu hause bleibt das virus nicht
weitergeben und nicht bekommen könnt
macht ihr es uns leichter wir sind
wirklich am boden
was dem gesundheitswesen an ressourcen
fehlt bekommt es an zuwendung von seinen
bürgern donnerstagabend tauchte sich
selbst windsor castle in das blau des
national health service die königskinder
applaudierten sowie viele tausend briten
die dem medizinischen personal und sich
selbst mut zu klatschten für die
kommenden schweren wochen mut und
durchhaltevermögen braucht es auch bei
uns nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind in deutschland stand
heute 21 uhr 98 1765 infektionen durch
tests bestätigt experten schätzen die
dunkelziffer von infizierten die nicht
getestet wurden fünf bis zehnmal höher
ein
vielleicht mehr 1524 menschen sind in
verbindung mit combi 19 in deutschland
verstorben
entscheidend für die dynamik der
epidemie ist der zeitraum in dem sich
die zahl der erkrankten verdoppelt das
ist tatsächlich eine kurve die nach oben
gehen soll
schutzmaßnahmen und kontakt
beschränkungen sind ja dafür da das
virus auszubremsen soll immer mehr zeit
brauchen bis es die zahl seiner opfer
verdoppelt
das ging sehr dramatisch los anfang märz
war es alle zwei tage
heute sind es nur noch 9,6 tage endziel
ist natürlich dass es gar keine
steigerung mehr gibt man sieht der kurve
an schulschließungen und eine woche
später kontakt beschränkungen zeigten
wirkung über lockerungen will die
bundesregierung aber erst reden wenn
diese kennzahl bei 12 bis 14 tagen
landet das ist also zukunftsmusik im
hier und jetzt müssen aufgaben gelöst
werden die mit ganz einfachen mitteln zu
lösen wären wenn die regierung auf
eigene experten gehört hätte die schon
vor sieben jahren prophezeiten dass so
ein virus über uns kommt und dann
einfachste dinge fehlen werden masken
und schutzbekleidung zum beispiel auch
in einer situation in der man jeden
schutz und fürsorge erwarten darf
eigentlich elisabeth schmidt über
hoffnungsvolle junge frauen rachel
schröer muss jetzt sehr stark sein
sie hat wären wie lange es dauern wird
bis zur geburt kann niemand genau sagen
und ihr partner darf jetzt nicht bei ihr
sein
corona schutzmaßnahmen im klinikum das
ist schon schwierig genug jetzt gratis
situation so ohne partner sind auch
nicht besuchen darf und würde der jetzt
auch nicht mehr mit den kreißsaal dürfen
muss unvorstellbar für uns zahlreiche
kliniken haben väter und angehörige
bereits aus kreißsaal und wochenstation
verband angst vor infektionen angst
davor dass das eh schon knapp bemessene
klinikpersonal ausfällt denn es fehlt
massiv an schutzkleidung nicht nur in
den kliniken sondern auch bei den
freiberuflichen hebammen steigen die
virusinfektionen weiter an so befürchtet
der deutsche hebammenverband mit der
bedarf an schutzmasken für die
geburtshelfer drastisch steigen auf etwa
400.000 pro monat
die hebammen sind nicht unbedingt
ausgestattet mit schutzkleidung momentan
ist die über den freien markt nicht zu
erhalten
die aufsuchende betreuung der frauen
kann im moment in dem rahmen wie wir es
gewohnt sind überhaupt nicht stattfinden
schwangere regelmäßig abtasten mögliche
komplikationen erkennen derzeit nicht
leistbar ohnehin auch vor corinna gab es
schon zu wenige hebammen in deutschland
betreut eine hebamme mehr als doppelt so
viele gebärende
in anderen europäischen ländern dabei
sind sie für schwangere wie ines stärke
ungemein wichtig ist jetzt in dieser
zeit gerade ein sehr großes für mich man
hat noch mal eine ganz andere bindung
aktion im arzt es ist so dass mein kind
sehr groß und es muss ein eingeleitet
werden zwei wochen er ist dann auch
schon mal sehr schwierig für mich weil
ich da auch selbst die angst vor der
einleitung und dann ist da noch die
angst sich mit dem corona virus
anzustecken
laut experten scheint der
krankheitsverlauf bei schwangeren und
jungen müttern zwar eher mild zu sein
doch was ist mit den babys die
neugeborenen können krank werden
beispielsweise eine studie zeigt bei 33
geburten von corona infizierten
schwangeren dass drei neugeborene krank
wurden aber keinen fatalen verlauf also
einen leichten verlauf gezeigt habe ralf
schröer hat die bangen stunden alleine
fast geschafft im kreißsaal ist ihr
partner dann wieder zugelassen für das
klinikum leer steht fest diese nähe ist
sogar medizinische sinnvoll
auf diese weise kann man auch viele
komplikationen die eventuell auftreten
können vermeiden
die unterstützung die seelische
unterstützung aber auch teilweise
körperliche unterstützung der
angetrauten person ist enorm wichtig die
ersten lebensstunden des kindes
gemeinsam erleben dieses familienglück
ist zu corona zeiten zu etwas ganz
besonderem geworden
es ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her
dass väter im kreißsaal eine seltenheit
waren und wenn sie kamen sind sie
reihenweise umgefallen andere zeit
corona fakten von heute compact gepackt
von kai felix jochens
in griechenland ist ein weiteres
flüchtlingslager unter quarantäne
gestellt worden nachdem ein 53 jähriger
afghane positiv auf das corona virus
getestet wurde
der mann sei in ein krankenhaus nach
athen verlegt worden
in den griechischen flüchtlingscamps
leben insgesamt rund 100.000 menschen
allein 40.000 auf ägäis-inseln ein eu
notfallplan sieht jetzt vor
schutzbedürftige auf das griechische
festland zu bringen oder in leere hotels
auf den inseln selbst das corona
hilfsprogramm der bundesregierung wird
mit rekordausgaben einhergehen rund 353
milliarden euro sind grundsätzlich ein
geplant garantien etwa für kredite
kommen in der höhe von rund 820
milliarden euro hinzu in der summe 1273
milliarden euro damit entspricht nur das
hilfspaket in etwa dem 3,5 fachen des
gesamten geplanten bundeshaushalts
[Musik]
bayern will pflegekräften einen
steuerfreien bonus von 500 euro zahlen
das kündigte ministerpräsident söder an
die angestellten leisteten einen großen
dienst der auch finanziell anerkannt
werden müsse bayerns pflege vereinigung
wertete die geplante zuwendung als
positives signal
sie könne jedoch nur der anfang sein für
viele hamburger endete der wochenendtrip
ganz ungewohnt an der grenze zu
schleswig-holstein bis mindestens zum 19
april gilt für touristen und
tagesausflügler ein einreiseverbot
trotz blauem himmel und sonne die
allermeisten menschen in deutschland
hielten sich am wochenende an die
kontakt beschränkungen
[Musik]
immer aktuelle zahlen und fakten über
corona über rückschläge und
hoffnungszeichen auch im weltweiten
vergleich finden sie auf zdf heute dort
auch die wichtigsten gespräche und film
berichtet jederzeit wie alles online und
nun nachrichten von grundlage für die
zeit nach corona hat bayerns
ministerpräsident söder steuersenkungen
gefordert um die wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln solle der staat zudem die
auto industrie stärken und den kauf
umweltfreundlicher fahrzeuge
unterstützen sagte er der bild am
sonntag ebenso wie finanzminister scholz
spd forderte er ein massives
konjunkturprogramm
kritik kommt von spd chef walter borjans
der bund könne die milliardenausgaben
und die beschlossene neuverschuldung
nicht abtragen indem man die
staatseinnahmen senke sagte er der
augsburger allgemeinen
in der ukraine ist in der sperrzone um
das ehemalige atomkraftwerk tschernobyl
ein waldbrand ausgebrochen gefahr für
die bevölkerung besteht laut
ukrainischem katastrophenschutz nicht
etwa 140 feuerwehrleute sowie zwei
löschflugzeuge sind seit gestern im
einsatz um die flammen zu bekämpfen
erschwert werden die löscharbeiten durch
die radioaktive strahlung
laut behörden ist eine fläche von rund
100 hektar betroffen
nach der messerattacke im südosten
frankreichs bei der zwei passanten
getötet und fünf verletzt wurden laufen
die ermittlungen wegen terrorverdachts
nach der festnahme des mutmaßlichen
täters kamen zwei weitere sudanesen in
polizeigewahrsam
bei dem hauptverdächtigen wurden
dokumente gefunden in denen sich der
mann darüber beschwert so wörtlich in
einem land von ungläubigen zu leben
in bremerhaven ist für hunderte urlauber
eine südamerika kreuzfahrt vorzeitig zu
ende gegangen
das schiff mit rund 1000 menschen an
bord legte dort an
gestern war ein passagier der an
vorerkrankungen litt verstorben
er wird nachträglich auf corona getestet
die reiserückkehrer sollen sich zunächst
freiwillig für 14 tage in häusliche
quarantäne begeben
die bedrohungen durch carola hat eine
alte gefahr wieder aktuell gemacht den
großen bruder den totalen
überwachungsstaat die vision des films
und des erfolgsromans von george orwell
1984 diesmal natürlich als schutz für
die bürger dieses argument zog schon in
orwells megastadt und es zieht heute in
china bürger dort akzeptieren totale
überwachung weil sie doch einen guten
zweck erfülle
bei uns wird diskutiert über eine corona
app die aufzeichnet wo man sich
aufgehalten hat wer da sonst absichtlich
oder zufällig in der nähe war
das würde eine sehr dichte überwachung
und sie könnte sehr bald beginnen
jutta sonne wald und alexander pohl über
chancen risiken und nebenwirkungen
im kampf gegen einen unsichtbaren feind
hört die bundeswehr auf das kommando der
wissenschaft 50 soldaten bilden
testweise eine corona infektionskette
nachvollziehbar per handy 180 experten
unter anderem am fraunhofer
heinrich-hertz-institut entwickeln eine
software die ohne persönliche daten aus
kommt dass die akzeptanz
die app gibt jedem handy eine anonyme
identifikationsnummer per bluetooth
kennen sich die handys in einem abstand
von zwei metern gegenseitig und
speichern die verschlüsselten nummern
der kontaktpersonen wird eine person
positiv getestet geht diese information
ans robert koch institut per push
nachricht werden dann alle
kontaktpersonen des infizierten
informiert so sollen infektionsketten
schnell unterbrochen werden
das alles rettet in deutschland münchen
leben
und das ist eins von vielen werkzeugen
und wir bauen immer mehr werkzeuge auf
um die gesundheitsämter zu unterstützen
mit apps zur nachverfolgung von
infektionsketten konnte man in
asiatischen ländern erfolge verzeichnen
dort werden sensible daten wie
telefonnummer standort oder
kreditkarteninformationen gespeichert
auch gesundheitsminister jens sparen
wollte ursprünglich handy standortdaten
zu corona bekämpfung nutzen mittlerweile
aber findet das anonymisierte modell
großen zuspruch doch auch hier gibt es
tücken
nicht jeder hat ein gerät vorrätig auf
dem web laufen kann insbesondere hat
nicht jeder ein smartphone
man wird also überlegen müssen ob man
vielleicht geräte an die
bevölkerungskreise ausgibt die
typischerweise weniger solche geräte
haben also zum beispiel ältere menschen
kinder menschen mit behinderung die
münchner firma seos ist spezialisiert
auf krisen früherkennung durch
künstliche intelligenz in der korona
krise nutzen die experten unter anderem
daten von gesundheitsämtern
krankenhäusern und dem
robert-koch-institut so können sie
präzise vorhersagen bis auf
landkreisebene erstellen wir sehen dass
landkreise unterschiedlich ausgestattet
sind mit der medizinischen versorgung
stichwortes intensivbetten die
landkreise haben eine gewisse zahl an
corona fällen und das miteinander in
überdeckung zu bringen zu sagen wie viel
hilfe ist da wie viel corona fälle wie
muss ich reagieren das ist die großteil
große vorteil des modells
währenddessen wird in der
julius-leber-kaserne in berlin weiter
die korona app getestet
in deutschland könnte sie ab mitte april
verfügbar sein
die technologie soll am ende in ganz
europa eingesetzt werden
sprechen wir mit dem daten
rechtsexperten und aktivisten ulf meyer
er hat dem bilderbuch lebenslauf eines
top juristen an deutschen und
amerikanischen universitäten war schon
anwalt menschenrechtler richter
mitarbeiter an verfassungsgerichten ein
schütze der bürgerrechte speziell auch
im digitalen guten abend herr meier
guten namen nach mainz jemand wie sie
ist also tatsächlich für für so eine
verfolgung software
ja denn es lohnt sich in diesem fall
sehr genau hinzuschauen app ist nicht
gleich ab es gibt einen sehr sinnvoll
ein
bereich für solche corona tracing apps
nämlich die nachverfolgung von kontakten
denn wir müssen uns immer klar machen
dieses virus hat eine besonders
tückische eigenschaft menschen sind
längst infektiös können andere menschen
anstecken bevor sie überhaupt spüren
dass sie selber krank werden und eine
solche tracing app erlaubt es menschen
zu warnen dass sie sich möglicherweise
infiziert haben dass sie besser zu hause
bleiben sollten längst bevor diese
menschen selbst krank werden und
deswegen können tracing apps einen ganz
entscheidenden zeitvorteil bieten
gegenüber anderen verfahren tracing ab
dass du so einen schönen neutrales wort
auf deutsch heißt es nachvollziehen oder
nachspüren menschen die da unterwegs
waren da gebe ich wer auch immer hinter
der app stehen wird eine menge daten
über mich bekannt und meine kontakte
bekannt und kann doch nicht sicher sein
dass es wirklich dann so nutzt wie
manche behaupten dazu ist also ob das
tatsächlich was nützt ist endlich eine
frage die wir vor allem den
medizinerinnen und medizinern stellen
müssen das ist nicht meine expertise was
ich ihnen aber sagen kann ist dass es
durchaus möglich ist solche apps in
einer weise zu gestalten dass wir uns
auch aus der perspektive des
datenschutzes hier keine sorgen machen
müssen denn beispielsweise sollen die
apps die in deutschland diskutiert
werden gerade keine ortsdaten speichern
das ist ganz wichtig es geht allein
darum zu speichern
welche zwei handys sich in einer
bestimmten gefährlichen weise nahe
gekommen sind wir dran ist ich denke
natürlich achten habe das ist ja der
viel interessantere teil also in welchem
stadtteil ich mich mit dem oder der
getroffen haben
das sollen diese apps gerade nicht
erkennen wer denn es ist letztlich egal
ob die virus übertragung möglicherweise
irgendwo an der bushaltestelle
stattgefunden hat im supermarkt oder im
bus oder an irgendeinem anderen ort also
die konkrete ortsinformationen zum
beispiel die gps daten werden von denen
in deutschland diskutierten apps nicht
einmal gespeichert sondern es geht
alleine um anonymous von handys in der
umgebung und die erlauben ist dann
ebenso anonym diese handys anzubringen
und sie an zu schreiben und zu sagen
vorsicht dieses handy ist in der letzten
zeit einem handy von einem menschen
nahegekommen der inzwischen auf corona
positiv getestet wurde
und natürlich muss man diese app genau
programmieren und man muss genau schauen
ob die tatsächlich datenschutz vorgaben
einhält aber das ist möglich und wenn
man das aus aber kontrolliert wenn man
auch den zentralen server aber
kontrolliert dann gibt es allen anlass
auch diesen apps zu vertrauen
ich frage mich über noch ob das wirklich
sinnvoll ist das so zu messen denn es
kann ja sein dass sich jemand für ein
paar minuten nahe gekommen bin aber es
war zum beispiel die schaufensterscheibe
eines ladens zwischen lohn oder am
flughafen der sicherheitsbereich links
und rechts davon
wir könnten lichtjahre auseinander seien
tatsächlich bilden die beiden handys
über bluetooth dann ihr beide seid
zusammen sind da nicht also unmengen von
fehlalarmen programmiert wenn einer der
beteiligten irgendwann mal später mit
corona identifiziert wird
sie haben völlig recht es wird
situationen geben in denen es auch zu
fehlalarmen kommt auf der anderen seite
können die algorithmen die hinter der
auswertung dieser bluetooth messungen
stehen ja auch genau wieder trainiert
werden stellen sie sich vor personen xs
infiziert und die kontaktpersonen von
personen iks werden jetzt gewarnt und
einige tage später meldet sich eine
dieser kontaktperson ihrerseits krank
dann war es der algorithmus im
nachhinein dass seine warnungen
zutreffend war
und andersrum funktioniert das genau so
gut das heißt man kann diesen
algorithmus trainieren und ganz wichtig
ohne dass man die identität der personen
dahinter kennen muss das ist natürlich
aus der sicht der privatsphäre ein ganz
zentrale eigenschaft eines solchen
systems und das system soll vom staat
verordnet werden oder wie soll das
funktionieren
nein aus meiner sicht sollte man hier
eindeutig auf freiwilligkeit setzen
das ist zum einen die grundrechts
freundlicher variante und zum anderen
ist sie finde ich in einer demokratie
auch die vorzugswürdige variante denn
zunächst mal bevor man über staatliche
zwangsmittel auch nur nachdenkt muss man
an die vernunft der menschen in
deutschland appellieren dass wir alle
einen beitrag leisten dazu diese
epidemie stoppen zu können und damit
auch die sogenannten lockdown maßnahmen
möglichst bald aufweichen können oder
lockern können und das wird so sagen
jedenfalls die medizinerin mediziner nur
möglich sein wenn es uns gelingt
infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen und zu
stoppen und in einem solchen konzept
denke ich kann eine app eine ganz
zentrale rolle spielen wird der staat
uns dann einen deal anbieten wir lockern
die kontakt beschränkungen wenn dafür
ihr akzeptiert dass eure bewegungen und
begegnungen
wie auch immer irgendwo elektronisch
ausgewertet werden ich würde das nicht
einen deal nennen denn deals haben wir
mal so einen oku ich denke aber das ist
letztlich eine verhältnismäßigkeit über
überlegung ist wenn es uns gelingt mit
hilfe einer solchen app infektionsketten
zu stoppen dann ist jedenfalls kein ganz
so strenger lockdown mehr erforderlich
wie wir uns zurzeit erleben
das heißt also man kann dann guten
gewissens vorsichtig anfangen die zügel
etwas lockerer zu lassen ohne dass uns
die infect infektionszahlen und die
krankheitszahlen so durch die decke
gehen dass unser gesundheitssystem
überlastet wird
da ist eine interessante beobachtung bei
umfragen zu machen
die menschen akzeptieren mit über 90%
diese doch sehr drastischen begegnungs
beschränkungen die wir im moment haben
aber wenn man fragt wollt ihr so eine
app dann ist die antwort etwa
fifty-fifty das bedeutet sie werden noch
eine menge überzeugungsarbeit leisten
können
wer weiß vielleicht war dieses gespräch
ein erster versuch für sie vielen dank
ich danke ihnen und einem schon amt ihn
auch über nein wir kommen rüber zu den
nachrichten von kunden die pandemie
überschattet auch die wichtigsten feiern
des christlichen kirchen jahres das
osterfest zu beginn der karwoche hat
pabst franziskus mit nur wenigen
priestern den palmsonntags gottesdienst
gefeiert
dabei wird an den einzug jesu in
jerusalem erinnert wenige tage vor
seiner kreuzigung der papst forderte
wegen der dramatischen situation der
pandemie die gläubigen zu häuslichem
gebiet auf die messe im petersdom konnte
man online mit feiern
atomkraftgegner dürfen trotz corona
morgen in münster gegen einen
bevorstehenden transport von uran
material protestieren
zunächst hatte die stadt die mahnwache
verboten
dagegen klagten die organisatoren
darunter das aktionsbündnis münsterland
gegen atomanlagen
nun fand man einen kompromiss die
aktivisten müssen mundschutz tragen und
ein meter fünfzig abstand von einer
halten fliegender corona krise ist der
bedarf an schutzmasken weltweit wie wir
wissen enorm sie zu bekommen bleibt
schwierig der flugzeugbauer airbus hat
weitere vier millionen masken von china
nach hamburg geflogen
zum teil gehen sie in deutschland an
medizinische einrichtungen zum teil nach
frankreich spanien und großbritannien
laut airbus wurden mit mehreren flügen
bereits sechs millionen masken nach
europa gebracht und jetzt geht's bei uns
ab in berlins clubszene
es ist aber nicht mehr viel mit club
solche bilder hier sind erinnerungen der
neue türsteher heißt corona und lässt
überhaupt keinen mehr rein
da stehen ein gutes stück berlin
lebensfreude und ein multi multi
millionen business auf messers schneide
ist doch klar dass die sich was
einfallen lassen
und genauso klar dass unser budget
carsten behrendt sich kamera schutzmaske
handschuhe und presseausweis greift und
aufmacht in die szene und gegen dessen
gegen ende seines berichts sagt der
club-besitzer für mich den satz des
tages
mindestens
hoch oben auf parkdeck sechs der
neukölln arcaden thront der klunker
kranich drinnen im club legt die erste
dj auf kein mensch auf der tanzfläche
corona blues
[Musik]
den ersten moment haben wir glaube ich
noch das gefühl gehabt irgendwie den
laden endlich für uns und im nächsten
moment war es aber ganz klar auch
scheiße
wir haben den laden nur für uns wir
hatten gerade erst wieder frisch das
team aufgestockt haben 65 arbeitnehmer
gehabt mussten jetzt erstmal in
kurzarbeit schicken werden
wahrscheinlich einige noch kündigen
müssen musiker spielen jetzt vor
menschen mit masken berlins clubs
antworten auf die krise
mit kreativität mal schön dass wir
überhaupt spielen könnten weil zwei
wochen wurden alle unsere auftritte
abgesagt und jetzt dürfen wir noch
einmal spielt die korona krise hat
berlins clubszene den stecker gezogen
stillstand bei einem aushängeschild der
hauptstadt 200 millionen euro
jahresumsatz 9000 arbeitsplätze
einige künstler und angestellte haben
bereits soforthilfen erhalten viele club
betreiber aber bereits vor corona
steigenden mieten ausgesetzt zittern
die große anzahl der klubs halten keine
zwei wochen durch mit ihren rücklagen
viele haben eben auch nur prekäre mit
verhältnisse also für eine begrenzte
zeit das heißt auch keine keine bank
wird den klub cen kredit geben der
rettungsanker heißt selbsthilfe mit
streaming jeden abend treten djs auf
jeden abend in einem anderen klub die
menschen mit den masken filmen sie
senden das notsignal live über das
internet tausende schauen zu und spenden
schon mehr als 350.000 euro
einsame djs für einsame club banger
wenn man sich die djs dabei anschaut
und wenn die dann auch ganz gut abgehen
hat man schon so ein bisschen club die
stimmung auf jeden fall also hat
natürlich geholfen mir vorzustellen wie
viele leute da jetzt setzen natürlich
weiß man vaters die da sitzen und an die
zu denken einfach eine große hilfe
einblicke wo sonst strenge türsteher
eintritt verwehren
die sind vielleicht die systemrelevant
aber freude relevant würde ich sagen und
wir merken dass das feedback einfach
wirklich enorm ist von den leuten zu
hause und wir da etwas gutes tun
typisch berlin soll die idee jetzt
weltweit exportiert werden corona
geplagten clubs helfen zusammen tanzt
man weniger allein
sind vielleicht nicht systemrelevant
aber freude relevant mein spruch für die
kommende woche das kann ja jeder in
seinem bereich mal probieren schauen wir
soweit dass in diesen zeiten möglich ist
auf die termine der nächsten woche
simone friedrich übernimmt das raffael
da urbino der todestag des italienischen
malers jährt sich morgen zum 500
er gilt als einer der bedeutendsten
künstler der italienischen
hochrenaissance berühmt sind vor allem
seine madonnen bilder weil die bilder
zurzeit nicht den öffentlichen
ausstellungen gezeigt werden können
zeigen die staatlichen museen zu berlin
die werke auf ihrer website
[Musik]
in nordrhein westfalen bringt die
schwarz-gelbe landesregierung zur
wochenmitte das umstrittene epidemie
gesetz im landtag ein
es würde der regierung weitreichende
befugnisse geben zum beispiel
medizinisches material zu beschlagnahmen
oder beschäftigte im gesundheitsbereich
zu einsätzen zu verpflichten die
opposition hat verfassungsrechtliche
bedenken abgestimmt werden soll noch vor
ostern
[Applaus]
der ostersonntag wird im vatikan in
diesem jahr unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit gefeiert papst franziskus
wird den segen urbi et orbi auf dem
leeren petersplatz sprechen
wie schon am freitag vergangener woche
als er wegen der korona pandemie den
sonder segen urbi et orbi erteilt hatte
und dabei auch allein auf dem platz
stand
[Musik]
und das wetter in dieser karwoche wird
sonnig und einfach frühlingshaft schön
morgen scheint überall die sonne erst am
abend tauchen an der grenze zu den
niederlanden wolken auf bei mäßigem
südwind werden 18 bis 25 grad erreicht
an den küsten bleibt es noch etwas
frischer und auch danach überwiegt
sonnenschein harmlose quellwolken gibt
es nur in der nordhälfte bei bis zu 25
grad
wir bekommen gerade meldungen aus london
das premierminister boris johnson der ja
wegen einer corona infektion in selbst
quarantäne war ins krankenhaus gegangen
sei wie es heißt für untersuchungen